ya estamos familiarizados con la idea
del polinomio y ya hemos practicado el
sumar restar multiplicar y factorizar
polinomios lo que vamos a comenzar a
pensar en este vídeo es la idea de
división polinomio
por ejemplo si tenemos un polinomio
cuadrado que es x cuadrada más 3 x más 2
y lo quiero dividir entre x 1 pausa en
el vídeo y piensen a que será igual esto
porque tengo que multiplicar a x + 1
para que sea igual a x cuadrada más 3 x
+ 2 una forma de hacer esto es tratar de
factorizar x cuadrada más 3 x + 2 lo que
ya hemos hecho en varias ocasiones nos
preguntamos qué par de números al sumar
se dan 3 y al multiplicar se dan 2 los
números que se me ocurren son 2 y 1 por
lo que podemos expresar x cuadrada más 3
x + 2 como x + 2 x x + 1 y todo esto se
divide entre x + 1
si tomamos x 2 x x 1 y lo dividimos
entre x 1 a que será igual pues es igual
a x + 2 y si queremos ser precisos
matemáticamente decimos que esto se
cumple siempre que x no sea igual a
menos 1 porque si x es igual a menos 1
en esta o en esta expresión
estaríamos dividiendo entre 0 lo que
ocasiona muchos problemas matemáticos
pero podemos ver que para cualquier otro
valor de x siempre y cuando no se divida
entre 0 aquí esta expresión va a ser
igual a x + 2 esto se debe a que x + 2 x
x 1 es igual a lo que tenemos en este
numerador conforme avancemos en la
división polinomiales nos encontraremos
con cosas que no son tan fáciles de
dividir realizando factorización es por
eso que existe una técnica llamada
división larga polinomiales también
conocida como división larga algebraica
si esto les parece familiar es porque
aprendieron la división larga en cuarto
o quinto grado el cual es un proceso muy
parecido a este donde tomamos el x + 1 y
lo usamos para tratar de dividir x
cuadrada + 3 x + 2 aquí voy a hacer un
ejemplo muy rápido de esto pero en
próximos vídeos haremos ejemplos mucho
más detallados primero nos fijamos en
los términos de grado mayor aquí hay un
término de primer grado y aquí hay un
término de segundo grado
cuántas veces cabe x en x cuadrada pues
cabe x veces ponemos la x en la columna
de primer grado y luego multiplicamos x
x x + 1 x x x es x cuadrada x x 1 s x y
ahora restamos esto de esto quizá
comiencen a ver semejanzas con la
división larga que aprendieron a hacer
en la escuela hace varios años cuando
hacemos esto estos se cancelan y 3x
menos x es igual a 2x luego bajamos este
2 x + 2 ahora nos preguntamos cuántas
veces cabe x en 2x y la respuesta es que
cabe dos veces aquí arriba tenemos x + 2
y multiplicamos 2 por x es 2x y 2 por 1
es dos préstamos esto y no queda nada de
residuo 2 menos 20 y 2 x 2 x es cero en
este caso la división es exacta y nos
queda x + 2 que es exactamente lo que
tenemos aquí un escenario interesante
que también veremos a detalle en los
próximos vídeos es lo que podemos hacer
cuando la división no resulta ser exacta
por ejemplo si sumo 1 x cuadrada + 3 x +
2 quedará x cuadrada más 3 x más 3 y si
trato de dividir esto entre x 1 la
división no va a ser exacta pueden usar
cualquier aproximación una forma de
pensar en esto es que si sabemos que
podemos factorizar x cuadrada más 3 x +
2 entonces podemos decir que
x cuadrada más 3 x + 2 + 1 / x 1 esto es
igual a x cuadrada más 3 x + 2 / x + 1
más 1 / x + 1 y ya sabemos que esta
expresión de la izquierda siempre que x
sea diferente a menos uno va a ser igual
a x + 2 pero ahora tenemos este 1 que no
pudimos dividir con x + 1 nos queda 1 /
x 1 veremos esto con mayor detalle en
futuros vídeos lo que significa este
residuo y cómo podemos calcularlo si no
podemos factorizar lo como parte de lo
que tenemos en el numerador y cuando
hagamos la división larga polinomiales
veremos que el residuo sale al final
cuando terminamos de dividir veremos
ejemplos de esto en futuros vídeos